well they get you wow you got me there
sweet and die though ah but I should use
it oh oh yeah ah what a shot oh yeah
[ __ ] that was so sexy
cat hey Seb we are experts at the entire
of Los Santos look at that place look at
that city we own but you know what we
haven't owned what's that sir stuff that
other people are made that's true and
you know what that's why we're here on
the vine would sign because if we're
gonna look at things that other people
have made we should look at the first
man-made object ever created did you not
up in the earliest of the 18th century
yeah I uncovered this sign made of
Coronado knows what it means nothing
just know and you never figured out
quite what it references of all language
should we go and endeavor on a couple of
user-made death matches and races
perfect idea ok let's begin by first
race to the bottom i'm in la luz I'm in
the lead opening opening I went oh I
think that's what you called a photo
finish oh it definitely is all right so
this one's called jump and die is the
objective to die I guess oh here comes a
job chit tough spot it no I jumped a
second Z but I slip but death well i
think i suppose what jump and die i
don't i look at this set I don't like
this at all oh I don't understand how
did I die and you live push are you
[ __ ] her that's my name this is the
big one all right Oh tree Oh God ah the
tree got me oh nice smooth landing
landed ah what a what a jump oh oh I
finished Oh nailed it oh good landing
almost a sweet finish I like that one
that was fun let's do that one again
haha enjoy hate enjoy much enjoy that
tree come on we got to improve our
jumping ah letter jumping there we go
nothing but forward flips or slideways
flips oh I'm gonna nail it no no no no
hahahahahaha buddy oh thanks you totally
ready to meet yours very welcome let's
go get it go oh come on bit more Gunny
more gonna dangle over the angle
hahahaha to you haha I made it we
yoshida I know I know saving ryan's
privates all right they must be saved
well I think it's me versus you is it a
well and it's just a choice of oh this
is great a choice of vehicle okay oh wow
I like I like look at this I'll got luck
oh yeah first kill em Oh something to
wait to blow up but I think it's
probably me yeah that's all right we got
plan on jumping out I've got a plan fire
main gun [ __ ] my blood involved jumping
out and smashing my face against the
wall Oh what does nothing here this
alive oh is that it oh god damn it no
why are you going for that go for the
giant plane there's always knock any
wings yeah not too how does it not oh
you're right this one's great got you
where I want you ah oh hey friend Oh get
it ha oh oh you're right to you Oh what
yeah i'll use my bullets get in one get
in to get into thing get anything [ __ ]
quick quick quick quick quick alright
said I see your game well my game is
kill you I'll great a pistol where are
you I'm like a really obvious target
you're also not flying very oh oh you
falling haha surprise he's [ __ ] there
you are oh [ __ ] hahaha I like how you
ricocheted off the ground there oh my
face well I get you wow you got me
though sweet and die though ah would I
she is it oh oh yeah ah what a shot oh
yeah [ __ ] that was so sexy
coming coming away whoa yes oh my gosh
you again [ __ ] ah oh god this is
not the way alright so it turns out
shooting planes out of this guy from a
tank really easy
oh yeah it's ball you we kiss I'm
shocked love that's okay the best thing
there we go so this should be fun with
more people I guess right oh wait ha I
don't know i think i crashed and it took
you out Oh crud I'm dead again how'd you
do God as soon as you hit a thing you
die yeah love it can you go out the edge
no no you can't go off the edge so with
a smooth smooth into the corners and
then let I didn't release yeah that was
fun with more people I bet all right be
trace I said let's race like gang
members let's go like this same idea
haha catch new belly are you yes me on
them right here but they are you a
straight into it is a great oh god you
get points for hitting the people's OD
yeah do you really know oh [ __ ] was a
gruesome death this is not really a
beach race though is it simpler without
only on the beaches on the beach none of
it no way thats what huh oh that one had
a jump I didn't take the jump I missed
the jump T oh look the finishing line I
will take that though Sean cam yes I
love saving ryan's privates oh they need
to be saved and safe locked away now for
another year yeah I only come out once a
year how often do your privates commence
their daily daily every single they are
they safe worried now Never Say Never
Say Never s'okay we've now defeated los
santos and we've defeated everything
ryan and his privates had to offer us as
well and it was great and they made up
what hahaha hellooo to you Ryan yeah ah
ok well so I think you know what's wrong
with you man relax nursing some sort of
thing for Heights yeah we're gonna we're
gonna finish this one in a new short
iron saving ryans private style yeah ok
I'm this kind of three we're gonna run
for our helicopters yeah get in and the
first person to turn around and shoot
the other one it's like some sort of
weird jewel okay
helicopters okay 3821 cheese it oh you
really slow off you're saluting okay
quick get it and i get in we're neck and
neck oh sad oh I'm flying as well oh you
busted yes haha I admire your guts going
for the gun though yeah all right Thank
You Ryan
you